bonsoir et expo merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france vous avez on
s'en souvient joué un rôle décisif en
dénonçant les pratiques d'évasion
fiscale et de blanchiment de fraude
fiscale en bande organisée de la banque
ubs vous suivez aussi de très près la
sphère julian assange que vous
connaissez bien ce feu vert des députés
français ce soir pour la proposition loi
sur les lanceurs d'alert c'est une
petite victoire vous êtes satisfaite ça
va vraiment changer les choses
est ce qu'on peut dire pour être positif
c'est qu'en fait des histoires comme la
mienne qui dure depuis 15 ans pour
peut-être parler de dieu un songe à
l'instant et tant d'autres histoire qui
dure depuis plus d'une décennie
permettent justement à ce qu'aujourd'hui
il ya un cadre légal et qu'en gros ceux
qui vont arriver derrière nous soit un
petit peu mieux protégés que nous
maintenant attention parce que le focus
est mis sur le mécanisme de l' alerte
sur le mécanisme du lancement d' alerte
moi je n'ai pas entendu parler de la
correction des fraudes qui sont révélés
par exemple si je vous prends le dossier
des banques parce que je suis
directement concerné donc par ce dossier
ubs on a récemment eu les honneurs à
people on peut se demander donc à quoi
ont servi des alertes comme les miennes
puisque les corrections n'ont pas été
faites et la preuve c'est que des
dossiers comme les miens qui ne sont pas
gérées depuis 15 ans bah ça évite à ce
qui est des lanceurs d'alerté dans mes
banques où on en avait un depuis depuis
des années il ya quand même un silence
absolu parce que les gens sont pétrifiés
on leur dit qu'effectivement tout
devient beaucoup plus transparent et en
fait c'est pas vrai alors au final
on va demander donc avec cette loin aux
citoyens de se comporter comme s'ils
étaient des autorités de contrôle et
c'est un petit peu moins ce qui me
sonne à l'esprit si vous voulez parce
qu'en fait nous des gens comme moi ont
été punis de faire le travail de ceux
qui ont failli de ceux qui étaient là
pour contrôler et de ce qu'il était là
pour nous protéger donc il faut faire un
petit peu aussi attention parce que
j'aimerais bien moi je dois pas être la
seule à vouloir plutôt parler de la
correction des fraudes en même temps que
la protection des lanceurs d'alerté et
que ce serait bien d'ailleurs par
rapport à ça qu'on entende des mots
comme la responsabilité comme l'éthique
et comme l'exemplarité alors il est
indispensable de protéger david contre
goliath a résumé sylvain wasserman le
rapporteur modem de cette proposition de
loi qu'est ce qu'il veut dire par là
c'est vraiment la réalité
des choses david contre goliath
c'est gentil qu'il puisse en parler
comme ça c'est selon l'expression que
j'ai conçu par le toulonnais sont donc
j'aime bien qu'on prête mes expressions
ça veut dire qu'elle sert vraiment à
quelque chose et qu'elles permettent
d'alerter maintenant au delà des mots
comment se fait-il qu'il n'y ait aucune
action il n'y a absolument aucun soutien
et en faites ce que je dis n'est pas
tout à fait exact c'est à dire que
certains lanceurs dallaire qui sont
considérés comme des sur lanceur d'alert
et méritent l'attention des médias
l'attention des associations l'attention
des syndics un l'attention des comités
de soutien et que d'autres ne mérite
aucune attention c'est à dire que tout
ça c'est à géométrie variable
il faut quand même faire très très
attention à ce que ce soit pas encore
défilé qu'ils soient mis pour aller
attraper des petits poissons pendant
qu'on ne s'occupe un des gros poissons
et que c'est ça la france
bardon comment vous expliquer justement
qu'il ya certes un focus sur certaines
affaires et beaucoup moins sur d'autres
et bien c'est que certaines affaires
doivent être justement bien plus
dérangeante parce que là on va parler
d'un autre mot qui est le mot corruption
que l'on emploie absolument jamais vous
voyez là on entend par les danseurs
alerte mais on alerte sur on alerte sur
des dysfonctionnements bien évidemment
en alerte sur des actions qui sont
illicites qui sont illégales en alerte
aussi sur de la corruption et de la
corruption sismique si la france a
refusé jusqu'à présent les îles de
julian assange s'est bien effectivement
que tout ce qu'il a dénoncé sa pose un
véritable problème au plus haut niveau
donc moi je n'y crois pas à cette loi de
protection de lanceurs d'alert pour tous
tant que justement la france n'est pas
capable d'être
cohérente par rapport à ces actions
parce que quand on nous parle de loin et
je vous dis c'est très très bien qu'il
ya un cadre légal puisque maintenant les
suivants vont pouvoir en bénéficier
mais encore faut-il que derrière les
lois soient appliquées que les fraudeurs
que les menteurs que les corrompus et
les corrupteurs soient pénalement
sanctionnée à très haut niveau
justement julien assange on le disait
les etats-unis qui réclament son
extradition au royaume uni les
parlementaires qui se sont mobilisés
pour lui offrir l'asile politique
est ce que vous y croyez vous pensez que
cela a des chances d'aboutir il que
julian assange a des chances d'obtenir
l'asile en france
je pense si vous voulez que
jusqu'à présent tout le monde s'est
désintéressé de ce dossier
pour des raisons diverses et variées
je dois être la seule personne en france
ou de langue française quitte eu un
livre préfacé par dieu l'un assange
vous le savez puisque je t'ai déjà dit
sur cette antenne ou rt france est la
seule
télévision à m'inviter et à me donner la
parole depuis 2010 est j'ai été
complètement censure est boycotté par
tous pour avoir lu ce livre préfacé par
julian assange ça veut vraiment dire que
des instructions ont été données par qui
par quoi je ne suis pas dans les secrets
des dieux en revanche aujourd'hui p mais
c'est important de le dire cette ce
projet de loi il a été signé à droite
comme à gauche donc il ya une forme de
consensus aujourd'hui et ben voilà les
choses ont changé les choses ont évolué
absolument j'allais dire merci de
m'avoir interrompre et c'est exactement
ça c'est à dire que l'espoir aujourd'hui
hélas ce n'est pas un combat de gauche
ce n'est pas un combat droite ce n'est
pas un combat du centre ce n'est par un
combat des extrêmes quelconque c'est un
combat de chacun parce qu'on parle là la
liberté de la presse de la liberté
d'expression on parle du pays des droits
de l'homme alors est ce que c'est le
pays des droits de l'homme justement qui
est capable de montrer qu'elle est à la
hauteur de ses ambitions ou est ce que
c'est un pays des droits de l'homme à
géométrie variable justement avec des
supers lanceur d' alerte et des sous
lanceurs d'alerté donc il suffit d'être
cohérent et moi je pense que justement
si la france veut être cohérente avec
cette loi de lanceurs d alerte elle doit
avant tout montrer l'exemple surtout on
prend la direction de l'europe à partir
du 1er et du premier chantier monsieur
macro prend la direction de leur parti
au 1er janvier donc en fait si on veut
montrer l'exemple il est bien évident
que c'est un problème justement de
droits de l'homme et c'est un problème
de 2
c'est un problème citoyens ça va bien au
delà injustement d'un problème que
politique politicienne comme on a bien
voulu nous faire croire jusqu'à présent
merci beaucoup c'est fanny j bons
lanceurs d'alertés d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur ft france